hello welcome to the lobby GameSpot's
weekly hangout every Tuesday at 2 p.m.
Pacific right here on GameSpot calm
first of all I just want to say
notorious Conor McGregor's where I'm a
dethrone shirt here did you guys enjoy
the fight on the weekend
enjoy that image you sent me that made
me very happy I didn't watch this Robbie
Lawler face like opened up
did he talk the whole time he did they
interviewed him when his mouth is open
UFC man you think video games are
violent what caused that mr. watch that
he got a kick or a punch or something
elbow probably right boom that was the
skulls of the Shogun sure didn't my
works for both yeah probably how the
audience thought that is what hot
Windows Phone game yeah but we're not
here to talk about skulls of the Shogun
we're here to talk about my Witcher 3
Wild Hunt ty root and eben
yes we've all been playing a bunch of
The Witcher 3 why level are you 25 what
level are 70 just kidding right what
species I downloaded a save game that
has a level 70 or did you yes on high
Larry's it also has 15 billion crowns
just decapitating people once way you
have a really nice loot chest right yeah
it was 3 mod but the point is we've all
played the hell out of that game and I
feel like the summer time is even like
it's perfectly setup for this because
then we can keep playing it but like the
sort of lack of games that's going on
and you laid a bunch again I haven't
even finished the freaking story don't
mean I feel like I've gotten way more
out of it than I were talking to Chris
earlier he's level 22 and he hasn't gone
for the skullery I spent an hour
yesterday trying to beat a fellow
Witcher on a horseback race because
gotta get that sad look us [ __ ] roads
for some reason when he gets to a bridge
freaks out and cross it like he just
stops ya know just been fixed soon but
yes so they have been fixing they've
been patching the game and they've been
adding a bunch of DLC and self-will got
opted out in a second but the big patch
that's come out is basically the one
that's allowed you to change up your
inventory and it's gotta back comes out
well later we actually know when it
comes up but I can't tell you
oh really apparently soon very soon okay
yeah so that's got like a bunch of fixes
which is kind of like traditional for CD
Projekt games to release oh okay that
everything works now patch but they've
also been adding a bunch of free DLC and
he talked to me about this you did a
bunch of videos on GameSpot basically
like
talking about each piece of DLC did
they're releasing like right over a
dozen pieces of DLC 16 right yes in
total so a lot of them are just armor
and cost new looks for the ancillary
characters like Jennifer interests and
this week's is this is seriously and and
then one of them was Gwent pack well
yeah so you guys are integrate I'm not
even going when that's another layer on
the top of my images who don't have the
energy to like dive into I just good up
to which you had to get to Gwen yeah I
want it to be a separate area on Steam
that's pretty good whatever stuff they
got anyway well um yeah they'll crossbow
yeah they cry so elite in quest and no
but yes so saving that for less because
that's what I was waiting I was like
yeah let's do some new quest because
these are the best things about this
game or the side quests right so there's
like what four or five I mean for the
quests and I've played them all they're
all really good they're all short but
sweet and yeah I think it just goes to
show that CD Projekt is super like good
at using their tools to make there's one
out with the high ten right oh yeah oh
yeah I can just like do the dialogue do
the animation do this thing you see the
cinematic shots of the of the when
you're talking even like program pigs to
be in it and like talk to you
spoiler and then it's like yeah they get
the there's a book they yeah they draw a
lot of references to the books in the
DLC quest because like hey why not like
this is their time for their superfans
to actually like digging harder and
stuff yeah for shin and they're the ones
that are gonna seek out these quests
like like me so it's like yeah they're
they're just awesome to play through but
like they're you know pretty quick quick
the eases and just armor and cool like
it's like some work so so saying like 16
deals geez yeah this is like it's a
little bit of a PR like in there co-op
for sure they get a win because
presumably then the roads that wants us
to purchase yeah which will happen but I
mean it is super cool like compared to
other games that would charge you for
all this you know like nickel and dime
you or what other games that would pull
back so much content the edge like my
problem with destiny being that
there's not that much in the game so
that's why everyone's buying all the DLC
right like they're giving you free DLC
in this game but you don't need no
cheese tactics here you know like it's
not like like we just we were discussing
Dragon Age Origins we're like got like a
free piece of DLC with the game and then
you go to like your camp and there's
some guy going hey by the way you should
buy this piece that you want to hear
about a story yeah breaking the
immersion but you're trying to [ __ ] me
over so this is not like that at all I
think this is more meaty stuff even a
SciQuest I think our media I mean they
they release the wolf gear like those
scavenger hunts are probably my favorite
part of that game I mean I spent so many
hours trying to hunt for like feline
armour Ursula and I'm right now I'm
doing the warmer yeah and like I spent
so much time last night just trying to
get that stuff and it does last a long
time because you know you have to be
certain levels and then you can go all
the way up to like level 34 stuff and
like it's like Master Craft gear so I
mean I I think there's some meaty
content there there's also some stuff I
don't want to talk about the spoilers
right there's amazing side quests
they're like the Scout goes most wanted
I think is what's called yeah that's a
really awesome one it's such a great
side quest it has relevance the entire
game I I once you get to that level I
encourage lockable player excellent so
that's that's all the stuff that they
were sort of like handing a piecemeal
over the past couple of weeks yes and
then also patch the game which is great
for people especially with the in terms
of the controller fixes I feel like a
lot of people been asking for and the a
notorious but yeah that's gonna be great
the blokes don't know love AB but on top
of my god later on this year we have
actual paid DLC coming at and that also
sounds like it's pretty expensive right
so according to the GOG on October 31st
they're gonna release the thing called
hearts of stone which must be a little
reference there but a 10 hour adventure
that takes place in no-man's land right
okay so they're just building more
quests in an existing land have they
said whether that's going to be post
campaign yes you can play the game after
the story's better it's probably it
probably is irrelevant to like just fits
right in yeah just just like give it
contract and it goes crazy probably
probably I don't know and that's the
smaller of two expansion packs that
they've they're talking about the big
one for 20 bucks I think well I don't
know what they are individually I think
you can buy a pass for 20 oh I know you
can buy a pass for 25 dollars there
99999 be good both for 25 25 it's
actually is pretty reasonable up in 30
hours of content yeah good yeah so
they're ragging on destiny too much yeah
but those ones cost more than $25 that's
true yeah uh no something to do
destiny defenders back yeah oh yeah the
second one which comes out in q1 slated
they don't know for sure is gonna be
called blood and wine 20 our thing with
a brand new area that's pretty cool new
area called Toussaint or something great
do you run it off in the books if I did
I don't know yeah I got too much there's
too much like what's your stuff man
there was weird words my keeping Irish
words thrown in there out of the context
that are like why did he say to shocked
that's weird that's not how you say
crack on crotch yeah so I like so much
man it just reminds me I feel like I'm
just talking to your people the entire
yeah it's great it's got a Garland's man
they're just owned by a bunch of people
from Belfast yeah and yeah so all that
stuff's coming out late next year so i
will be playing even more richer what
does this like make you feel about when
when you're because there's been so many
games that come at you know it's not
just the game that i keep mentioning but
like games like evolved for instance
yeah or like right up front they were
talking about here's our strategy this
would spend batman you sell skins yeah
right she's the best you get a few skins
like i mean it's a senseless greed oh no
secret like a lot of gamers feel burned
but i mean the fact is like you have a
lot of games can pass we just mentioned
Dragon Age Origins you had like things
like mass effect where you know Mass
Effect 3 there's like this like from
ashes DLC that you can buy for 10 bucks
yeah like it involves a very important
character there's some big integral part
right story yeah like why is this not
free and then you have things like you
have companies like Capcom who like
include the DLC in the disk yeah but
lock it behind the paywall essentially
you know so it's I think I mean
obviously I think people are learning
from their mistakes now what I like
about
CD Projekt RED is like they're clearly
passionate about their audience and what
their fans want and I think it's great
to see that content with that push for
content whether it's free Dilla see like
the 16 pieces that we're getting now and
in the expansion packs that are actually
you can call them UT expansion packs
yeah it's not like 2 to 3 hours of
experience it's more like you know you
get 30 you know and that's it's good
bang for your buck and I mean you know
despite the fact I still believe games
are cheaper
now than they ever have yeah sure
especially when you account for
inflation I still think that you're
getting a lot of value here and then
they clearly care they're they're
they're gamers too so they get it so
going forward do you think that like
sets a different precedent there because
we kind of for a while it looked like
we'd gotten used to getting nickel and
dimed post-release you think a game like
The Witcher because it's like had this
sort of widespread success its sold
really well it's been on like consoles
on PC and been critically lauded and
also like loves by gamers do you think
because this is the game that's done
this that like that it's almost like
setback that sort of push into nickel
and diming gamers that we've seen happen
for the past you know couple of years I
don't know because CD Projekt they were
they've been super smart and kind of
like sat back and watched what's
happened to the industry before they
like had a plan for this game and their
operating and it like such a big scale
now compared to what they were before so
they can like have a group of designers
make armor and kind of like have that
cost built in to the four million units
or the one price five million pre-orders
yeah like they have all this planned out
right and plus they're they're probably
operating at it like a little less of a
cost than say like your EA or something
cause it goes Holling already goes
further the dollar goes further there so
yeah it's it's hard to say because
they're private to so it's like they can
do whatever they want they can just look
as good as they want to look and gamers
will appreciate that and everybody
benefits and not beholden to some
shareholders or acquiring which to be to
be honest like that shouldn't they're
like the CD Projekt way would actually
benefit probably every company or like
it would be better for shareholders if
other companies did this you want a
trusting fan yeah I just don't think
they have that much they're not looking
far enough ahead they're looking at like
the quarter so they're like let's sell
this right now in the quarter thing and
CD projects like let's like build trust
with our gamers yeah and so they're
gonna buy five million copies of
freaking cyberpunk because they know
like well I guess if you're releasing a
game every you know three to four to
five years probably want to make sure
you're you've got people who are going
to support you and you release your next
game and that's the thing I mean you
look at games now there are plenty of
games that are short right we're talking
like four to six hours and there with no
replayability value whatsoever there are
$60 so yeah you don't like the widget
the bucks it's like a hundred plus our
experience not to mention you have all
that free DLC you were winning the the
favor of your audience at that point and
the trust and at some point they're
gonna look and like okay there's an
expansion pack
I played 16r I played a bunch of
SciQuest they released for free they
were actually good I can only imagine
what the expansion packs will be now
yeah they probably have a pretty good
percentage on the amount of people
that'll pick up their post-release
expansion pack I guess we'll have to
find out
Tyagi thank you so much coming on
talking about Geralt with me
[Music]